[Music]
let's go to josh in fort bragg north
carolina josh welcome to the ramsay show
hey gentlemen thanks a lot for having me
absolutely how can we help
talking about your fears in life so i
feel like it's a great introduction here
perfect bring it on come on dude
i'm active duty uh army uh my wife and i
the two kids are stationed at fort bragg
and um we're brand new to starting
financial peace we started about
christmas last year
and um
i felt like we've always been
financially savvy
but until starting your course and
figuring out that
i've got a negative net worth that was
uh pretty revealing
josh first uh man brother thank you for
blessing
me and my family with your service i'm
grateful for you and dude i remember
distinctly one of my best friends in the
world name's todd he's a banker when he
did my net worth with me and it was
negative and he laughed so hard he
almost threw up he was laughing so hard
i was in disbelief man i remember that
moment man it's a good friend i'm pretty
good i'm pretty good nope not well hey
that's step one that's right that's
right that's one you're doing great
what's your circumstance brother
yeah so
um
we just started financial peace
christmas well november of last year
um i bought a 22 toyota 4runner attaboy
they always make the bad decision right
before they join
i love it okay right before we're
pending right all right
it's about a 47 000 truck
i financed i financed 37
um and i had 20 000 in the bank
and so of course very first thing after
we started doing financial peace um also
my wife was pretty apprehensive about it
i threw all but a thousand dollars at it
and so i only i've got 17 000 remaining
on it
now the where things get a little bit
scary or sketchy for me is
um i've got a pending religious
exemption um with with this coveted
vaccine
and uh the threat is looming that
they're going to separate those of us
that get denied exemptions in june or
july
and so um i can i'm paying off right now
about 3 200 a month towards this truck
um
our our net take home is about 5 300 a
month
um
so at 17 000 owed on this i can have it
paid off in about five and a half months
or should i sell the truck
and
i could get about thirty two thousand
dollars in pocket by a twelve thousand
dollar
you know get some point
you can only get thirty two grand for
this truck i guarantee you no
guarantee no no sorry maybe maybe i um
didn't express the the numbers right so
if i if i can sell it for 50 or even
sell what i bought it there you go yeah
you will net you're saying you'll net 32
grand exactly i'll net 32
and then what's what i spend let's say
10 000 12 000 on a on a vehicle that's
safe for my family and then i've got
back to having 20 000 back in the in the
bank for
you know our three to six month
um emergency fund if you if you get
separated at june and july are you going
to lose this income
yes and that's and that's where that's
where things are scary for us because
okay i mean what's your household income
uh so right now um well i make gross
5400 but we live on base so i bring in
uh 3 500 because they take away your
your housing
yeah
this car feels like it's a large part of
your world net worth income
the car yeah
yeah and that's the point it's like i
mean i i feel
the whole reason we bought this vehicle
is because you know i've i've tinkered
around on eight thousand ten thousand
twelve thousand dollar vehicles
and my wife's like hey i'm tired of
driving these and so you know i just
finished a special operations training
here and so i'm thinking oh man i'm just
just rode the bus straight to
entitlement was like yeah i deserve this
nice truck yeah and now
dude there is
there is nobody no group of people that
i know of that are more awesome
more brilliant and make more ridiculous
car choices than my friends who are in
the service
like
and you know that dude
at least you didn't get a jeep with big
tires so you you're the family car so
good for you josh let's skip to the good
stuff yeah josh sell the truck man yeah
i want to take the what might happen in
june or july off the table okay okay
that's clouding this thing
you might lose your income and there's a
reality to that and if you think in any
job for any reason that hey come come
summer i might be out of a job then
obviously you need to be doing what's
best for you and your family like what's
that going to look like how am i going
to earn a living all that let's take
that off the table right now
george just nailed it this is a this is
too much car for your household income
right now whether you had this or not
you got a fifty thousand dollar car and
a sixty thousand dollar income it's it's
too much as is
so i would i would tell you to sell it
if you told me i got into special ops
team i'm gonna get deployed but i'm
gonna be there for the rest of my life
and making 65 grand i would tell you to
sell the car anyway
and i know your wife doesn't want to
keep driving that i get that um yeah
y'all just it's just you have a dollar
amount situation that you got to deal
with a reality you gotta you got to
think about it this way uh you said
you're tired of driving the car but
you're about to be tired of being broke
man and i'd much rather you be tired of
driving the car yeah and so make a good
decision for your family one day it can
be your goal to get that car again when
it makes sense for your income and your
family but right now you got a mess to
clean up